it's been 10 years since the Sandy Hook
Elementary school shootings 26 people
were shot dead including 20 children
between the ages of six and seven
at the time gun control Advocates hoped
it would be a turning point surely this
would catalyze Federal action to limit
the sale of assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines
but at the annual National vigil for
victims of gun violence in Washington DC
a tradition begun after Sandy Hook Joe
Biden who was the first president to
attend made it clear he wasn't satisfied
with what has been achieved such as the
gun control legislation passed last
summer together together we've made some
important progress
most significant gun law passed in 30
years but still not enough
even amongst Ardent supporters of that
law describe it as modest the key
provision was expanding background
checks for 18 to 21 year olds before
they buy a gun in the absence of the
bipartisan congressional action needed
for Meaningful gun control legislation
State legislatures have been acting
responding to public outrage following
mass shootings and instituting strict
regulations
for example following a high-profile
mass shooting Democrats in Virginia
passed a raft of gun control legislation
but those efforts have been put into
Jeopardy following a Supreme Court
ruling last year the court decreed that
only firearm regulations that were part
of the historical tradition of the US's
gun laws were constitutional for those
fighting gun control the courts have now
become the main weapon to roll back
whatever efforts have been passed
legislatively they say the ruling means
if a gun law wasn't on the books and the
18th or 19th century it isn't
constitutional there were very very few
restrictions extremely hard to find any
kind of restriction back then and that's
what the founding fathers wanted to keep
but lawyers fighting for gun control say
this is a misreading of both the ruling
and of History first they argue that
contrary to popular perceptions
restrictive gun permit laws were in
place by the late 19th century around
the country and they feel an assault
weapons ban is consistent with the
supreme court judgment
weapons are not for self-defense they're
not suited to self-defense they're not
used for self-defense it's about an
individual right to self-defense outside
of the home it doesn't say that it's
about a right to take a gun and walk
into a school and gun down a bunch of
kindergartners so the expectation is
that mass shootings will continue in
2023 as will bursts of outrage and calls
for something to be done but for now
meaningful gun control remains some way
off she ever turns the Al Jazeera
Washington